bueno pues este vídeo va a ser muy
entretenido porque voy a resolver está
integral la integral de 1 entre 9 x
cuadrada todo esto multiplicado por el
diferencial de x y nosotros ya sabemos
que cuando tenemos la forma cuadrada - x
cuadrada hacemos un cambio de variable
usando una sustitución trigonométricas
de x igual a veces el seno de teta sin
embargo en esta ocasión tenemos algo de
la forma cuadrada más x cuadrada por lo
tanto cuál va a ser mi cambio de
variable en este tipo de ocasiones el
mejor cambio de variable que yo puedo
hacer es decir x es igual a la constante
a que multiplica a la tangente del
ángulo theta bueno pues vamos a ver que
nos queda si hacemos el cambio de
variables nos va a quedar a cuadrada
masa cuadrada tangente cuadrada de teta
que es lo mismo factor izando en la
cuadrada cuadrada que multiplica a 1 más
la tangente cuadrada de teta y todo esto
de aquí
bueno de hecho se lo podemos probar eso
es lo mismo que a cuadrada que
multiplica al coseno cuadrado de teta
entre el coste no cuadrado de teta
coseno cuadrado entre coser un cuadrado
me da 1 y la tangente cuadrada de teta
es lo mismo que el seno cuadrado de teta
entre el cochino cuadrado de teta por lo
tanto tenemos el mismo denominador y los
podemos sumar entonces me va a quedar a
cuadrada que multiplica al coseno
cuadrado más el seno cuadrado de t está
entre el coseno cuadrado de teta pero el
coche no cuadrado de teta más el seno
cuadrado de teta es lo mismo que uno por
lo tanto simplificando todo esto me va a
quedar que es lo mismo que a cuadrada
que multiplica a la secante cuadrada de
teta y es justo a donde tenemos que
llegar entonces pues ya que tenemos esta
expresión lo que se me ocurre es hacer
mi cambio de variable y cuál va a ser mi
cambio de variable pues el denominador
es 9 más x cuadrada que lo podemos
escribir como 3 al cuadrado más x
cuadrada y aquí ya tengo que a vale 3
por lo tanto x va a ser igual haciendo
mi cambio de variable a tres veces la
tangente de teta y bueno si nosotros
metemos
x es igual a tres veces la tangente de
teta lo primero que sería muy bueno ser
sería despejar a teta por lo tanto voy a
pasar el 3 dividiendo y me queda que x
entre 3 es lo mismo que la tangente de
teta y si yo paso la tangente del otro
lado de la ecuación me queda que el
ángulo teta es el arco tangente de x
entre 3 y muy bien ya tenemos la teta
ahora lo que necesitamos es el
diferencial de x y para eso lo voy a
calcular de aquí el diferencial de x ya
visto en su forma diferencial me queda
que es 3 veces y la derivada de la
tangente de teta con respecto a teta es
lo mismo que la secante cuadrada de teta
diferencial de teta y bueno ahora sí ya
tengo todo lo necesario para poder
sustituir en esta integral haciendo mi
cambio de variable me queda uno por la
diferencia del x por la diferencia el x
es tres veces la secante cuadrada de
teta diferencia el dt está entre 9 más
equis cuadrada y 9 más x cuadrada pues
ya lo podemos ver de una manera mucho
más sencilla con el resultado que
obtuvimos hace rato 9 más x cuadrada es
lo mismo que a cuadrada secante cuadrada
de teta pues sería lo mismo que poner el
cambio de variable x igual a tres veces
gente de teta y haciendo todas estas
supersticiones me quedaría el final 9
que multiplica a la secante cuadrada de
teta por lo tanto esto iba de color
magenta y lo voy a escribir aquí me
queda que a cuadrada es nueve veces la
secante cuadrada de teta y sé que tal
vez me salte algunos pasos pero estoy
ahorrando tiempo para no poner aquí 999
y sumarle un 9 y factorizar el 9 y
después sacar el 9 por aquí y entonces
al final llegar a todo esto que ya
habíamos calculado que era a donde
llegaba mi cambio de variable y ahora si
ya tengo secante cuadrada que está
multiplicando y secante cuadrada que
está dividiendo por lo tanto se cancelan
y me queda que esto es lo mismo que un
tercio por la integral un tercio porque
es lo mismo que 309 por la integral de
la diferencial de teta y cosa más
sencilla es lo mismo que un tercio por
teta más mi constante de integración y
bueno ya casi acabamos ahora lo que hay
que hacer es la sustitución hacia atrás
de esta es igual al arco tangente de x
entre 3 por lo tanto me queda un tercio
del arco tangente de
y entre tres más una constante de
integración y hemos acabado esta
integral y qué bueno porque ya con esto
hemos creado armas para resolver
integrales de este estilo y además el
día de hoy resolvimos integrales de esta
forma cuadrada más x cuadrada haciendo
una sustitución de econométrica entonces
cada vez que no funcione una sustitución
normal piensa en que tal vez puedes
utilizar una sustitución trigonométricas
para resolver las integrales y también
encontrar la solución del problema así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo